JU-KAY KWEK: OK.
I think we're ready to go.
Good morning, everybody.
This is session 315.
As you can read from
the title, it's
about big data mashups.
My name is Ju-kay Kwek.
I'm in product management at
Google, and I lead the
BigQuery team.
For those of you who are a
little less familiar, just a
quick introduction.
BigQuery is a service that we
launched about a year ago.
It's a fully managed analytics
service in the cloud.
It lets you ingest
a lot of data--
multiple terabytes, hundreds
of terabytes--
interactively analyze that
data using the power of
Google's data centers, and
then securely share the
results, whether with your BI
tools, with the rest of your
team, and so forth.
Like I said, we launched the
service about a year ago, and
for my team, one of the most
exciting and gratifying things
has been working with some
leading customers.
Because we know the use cases
that this technology has been
used for inside of Google
in production for the
last couple of years.
And now that we've externalized
significant parts
of it, the functionality, we've
really been excited to
see, what are people going to
do with the technology?
And we would be here a long time
if I could list out all
of the use cases, but I thought
today we would talk
about just one.
And so it's with great pleasure
that today we have
with us Derek Stevenson
from Shutterfly.
Shutterfly was one of
our early customers.
They have a great use case we're
going to talk about.
And just for context, Derek
works on Shutterfly's
analytics team.
He leads the team responsible
for big data strategy and
analytics technologies.
So we've worked very closely
with them on what you'll see
are some really gnarly
problems.
Just a quick run through
of the agenda.
We're just going to do a little
bit of introduction
into what Shutterfly does, who
the customers are, why
analytics is really, really
important for a business like
Shutterfly, and walk through
what they did with BigQuery in
terms of integrating it into
their big data and analytics
infrastructure.
We'll go through a couple of
examples down at the code
level so that people get a good
idea about how we can
actually, in a very practical
way, get things like data
ingestion in the tooling set
up running very quickly.
We'll run through a couple of
query examples, and I think
you'll see the results
are quite fun.
And then we'll back out, and
we'll do about 10 minutes of
Q&A at the very end.
So with that, I'm going to hand
over to Derek, and he's
going to walk us through
today's presentation.
Derek?
DEREK STEVENSON:
Thanks, Ju-kay.
Thank you all for being
here today.
I'm excited to share some of
the learnings we came to
through our use of BigQuery.
As Ju-kay mentioned, we'll
outline some of the challenges
that we face with big data, what
it means to us, because
as many of you know, "big"
is always relative.
A quick introduction to
BigQuery, for those of you who
are not familiar with it.
I'll also talk about our
solution architecture, and as
Ju-kay mentioned, how it fits
into that broader picture.
Talk about some specific
examples from an analytic
standpoint that will hopefully
spark some ideas for how you
can apply it in your
own environments.
And of course, we'll wrap up
with conclusions and Q&A.
So I'd like to get a quick
show of hands.
How many of you have smartphones
that you regularly
take pictures with?
OK, as expected.
How many of you still
take pictures with a
point-and-shoot camera?
OK, a few less.
And how about SLRs?
OK, good.
So we have, obviously, healthy
engagement with photography
and the category.
I'd like to tell you a little
bit about Shutterfly as
background.
Our vision is to make the
world a better place by
helping people share
life's joy.
And it's a pretty aspirational
vision, but we do that through
the creation of photo products
such as photo books, cards,
and stationery, photo gifts that
are meaningful and that
often go hand-in-hand with
gift-giving occasions.
Shutterfly has been
around since 1999.
Last year, we had over $600
million in revenue, over 7
million customers.
And to give you an idea of the
scale of data that we're
dealing with, just one of many
data points is, how many
images do we deal with?
And in our case, it's 19 billion
images, and growing
faster every year.
So I'd like to do a
quick pop quiz.
Does anyone have any ideas
for what this might be?
Go ahead and shout it out.
AUDIENCE: DNA?
DEREK STEVENSON: Yeah.
When we were going through a
dress rehearsal, that was the
number one guess on this.
We've not quite perfected
sequencing our customers' DNA
for customer marketing purposes,
but maybe next year.
No.
So how many of you are
Tableau users?
I see a few hands out there.
So this is a visualization to
demonstrate events that occur
over a period of time.
And what this is, there's about
4,000 marks on this
graph, and each one of those
represents an image, a picture
that was taken at a
particular time.
It's all the images from my
account on Shutterfly, and it
spans about 10 years,
and each row
represents a discrete camera.
And when I first pulled this
data, I was sure I'd done
something wrong.
I couldn't believe that
there were that
many different cameras.
It turns out, though, that it
does, in fact, represent all
the different cameras that are
capturing memories that are
meaningful to me and
commemorating
a variety of occasions.
And it, I think, speaks to
the explosion of digital
technology and cameras and their
omnipresent status in
our lives, but also speaks to
the connections between people
and how images are so
meaningful to us.
And you can see that the
data is not random.
It commemorates, again,
occasions such as getting
married, or having children, or
going on family vacations.
The Stanford brainwashing has
begun, so if you have any
questions about how
to do that, let me
know after the talk.
So this is great stuff.
We've done a little
mini-analysis and
visualization on a data set.
What's the fuss?
Why is this a big deal?
Well, insight requires
interpretation, and we
happened to look at one specific
account, my account,
and a specific set of images.
But how do you scale that sort
of analysis to seven million
customers, to 19 billion
images and growing?
And how do you do it in a way
that is relevant and specific
to our particular business?
So one thing about Shutterfly
that's worth noting is we're a
very seasonal business.
About 50% of our revenue comes
in the fourth quarter.
So there's this compression
where we're making decisions
on a daily and sometimes
hourly basis.
And to do that effectively, to
derive insights and respond to
key business questions depending
on what customers
are doing, you need to be able
to do that very quickly.
So in order to tackle some of
those issues, oftentimes more
traditional approaches require
certain compromises around how
you deal with data.
You might do sampling, you might
pre-aggregate certain
results, and as a result, you
drop out some detail.
So what sometimes happens is
you're limited to a subset of
your customers, or a level of
detail with your customers,
that doesn't allow the
inevitable follow-up questions
that the business
is going to ask.
So what we want to try to do
here is tackle this carefully
and retain all of that
level of detail.
I think that's ultimately what
a lot of business owners are
after, is they want to have all
of that data available to
them at any time.
And yet when we tackle how to
solve those problems, we want
to do it in a way that is
adhering to key constraints,
key considerations that we
have as a business around
scale and performance.
So obviously, as I mentioned,
it's got to be fast, and it's
got to be, in some regard,
unlimited in how much data
you're going to be able
to put into it.
Also, we're trying to be
very cost-conscious.
So there's obviously ways
to tackle this--
if you have a huge, unlimited
budget, there are technologies
that are out there.
But with all the innovation in
the space, we believe there
are more cost-effective ways
to do some of this.
And the last is simplicity.
And what I mean by simplicity,
it's not just simplicity for
implementation, how do you stand
this environment up and
get running with it, but
also for adoption.
And what that means is, are
analysts comfortable using the
technology in a way that is
relevant to them and that
doesn't impose a huge
learning curve?
So at Shutterfly, I've been
there almost nine years now,
and from day one, data has
always been seen as a
competitive advantage.
And we as analysts are
responsible for focusing our
analytics efforts on
actual analytics.
What that means is, how do we
focus the attention at any
given time on a given business
problem to the right data set?
Not all of your data at any
given time, but for any given
business question you might
try to be answering-- the
questions that we answer in the
fourth quarter are very
different than those we answer
at other times of the year.
And we do that with a focus
on customer value.
How do we derive increased
customer value
through those insights?
We strongly believe in owning
our own data and methodology
and not relying on a third
party, if you will, to
accomplish that.
And we have an experienced
analytics team that helps us
use a variety of techniques
to get there.
For us, big data
is everywhere.
There's a wide variety
of applications.
And this is not an exhaustive
list, but it gives you,
hopefully, some ideas
of how it might
apply to your business.
I'll talk a little bit more
about the first couple
marketing mix models and
multichannel attributions.
So some of you may be familiar
with this, but the basic idea
is that marketing often has a
particular budget with which
they can invest in their
marketing channels.
And one common question that
we have is where should I
spend that dollar?
What's going to get me
the biggest return?
And it's a complex question to
answer, depending on the time
of year, depending on the
marketing channels
available to you.
So we're going to talk a little
bit more about that and
take this to hopefully a little
more specific example,
so you can perhaps draw some
connections to how you might
apply it yourselves.
So in this case, this is a
simplified view on it, but you
can get an idea of the
scale of the problem.
So we've got user data that's
in the millions of records,
user attributes that
go with that.
Marketing emails, when you're
thinking about all the emails
you send from a marketing
standpoint over a couple
years, when you're doing
year-over-year analysis, for
example, you can see how that
would quickly scale up into
the hundreds of millions.
And that starts to strain the
limits of our more traditional
approaches to dealing
with data.
The third is web traffic, and
that's really where the
problem presents itself.
You're in the billions of rows,
and in some cases, you
have hundreds of columns of
attributes that you're
collecting.
And when you try to
cross-reference these data
sets, it starts to break
down when you get into
that level of detail.
There's a variety of other
domains of data that this
applies to.
We already talked earlier
about image data.
There's web traffic data, social
and mobile are entirely
new categories of data that have
exploded over the last
couple of years.
So there's a variety
of applications.
So this hopefully looks pretty
familiar to many of you who
are dealing with data
warehousing and
data ingestion issues.
We're collecting data, storing
it, preparing it for analysis,
using a variety of tools to
dig into the data, and
ultimately it's with a focus
on acting on the data.
What decisions can you make as
a result of your insights?
Traditionally, the
responsibilities around
collection, storage, preparation
have been the
domain of IT.
So I wanted to get a quick
sense-- how many of you are
really on the IT side?
And how about on the other
side, analytics and more
business-oriented?
So what I want to try to do is
paint a picture that hopefully
for those of you on the business
side have a sense of
what IT's concerns are and vice
versa, and where we're
trying to go with this.
When you introduce an entirely
new category of data that is
much larger, perhaps, than
your systems have been
designed for, you run into a
number of issues, and IT
typically bears the
brunt of that.
How does IT deal with entirely
new categories of data, and
entirely new scales of data that
the analysts and business
owners are looking
to leverage?
And where we want to go with
this is, how do we work around
some of those constraints?
How do we start to enable some
of those pipelines in a more
efficient manner?
When you step back,
this is really a
multi-dimensional problem.
You've probably heard the terms
volume, variety, velocity.
We looked at some examples of
the dimensions you might be
looking at-- users, email,
traffic, web traffic.
And you might have aggregated
some of that data.
But as you know, as soon as an
analyst looks at the data and
understands something in that
aggregate, they're going to
say, well, what's the next
level of detail?
So you might be missing out on
some of the connections from
that more detailed data.
You might also through, for
example, mergers and
acquisitions, acquire
a new company.
And all of a sudden, it's your
job as an IT person to deal
with this entirely new category
of data that your
systems were never
designed for.
So how do you adopt certain
strategies to tackle that
effectively?
What I think probably many of
you in the room are familiar
with is when you talk to the
business, everyone just wants
all the data at any given level
of detail, and they
don't necessarily appreciate
some of the trade-offs.
So how do we fill that
gap with BigQuery?
A quick intro, or
resummarization, of BigQuery--
no limits on the volume of data
that you can put into the
environment, extremely scalable
and fast performance
on queries, a variety of ways of
interacting with it via SQL
as well as APIs, and then
interoperability with existing
tools such as Tableau,
Excel, and so forth.
So what we're striving for is
to go from this situation to
one more like this, where we're
doing a couple of things.
First, we're empowering analysts
to push back further
in that pipeline of data
analysis and processing and
enabling them without having to
reformulate the data into
structures that might be better
suited for analysis,
but as we talked about earlier,
bring certain
compromises.
One of the other things to note
here is that we're not
ripping out the old way of doing
things, necessarily.
We're finding complementary
ways to use them so that
BigQuery, at least at this
stage, is enabling us to deal
with these categories of data
that we otherwise have not
been able to deal with.
The other thing to notice is
that this isn't minimizing the
role of IT.
In fact, what we hope this
achieves is more efficiency
for IT, where they can spend
more time on the hard problems
that they're uniquely suited to
solve around collection and
management of these categories
of data that are bigger than
ever before.
If they don't have to spend
their time preparing data and
aggregating and building cubes,
I've been on the IT
side, and I can tell you
that's probably not the
funnest part of the job.
So we really think this enables
new insights and lets
you access all levels of detail,
web scale data, and
connect it with all of your
other transactional data.
And we firmly believe that this
is a critical element in
how we inform the product and
marketing strategies and
ultimately hopefully
bring a better
experience to our customers.
There's a whole host of ways in
which our customers use our
products, and many are very
innovative, and we want to
continue to support
those needs.
If you're like my son, at this
point you're thinking, let's
get on with it.
Let's see some real code.
This is a developer conference,
after all.
So I'll go into that in
some more detail.
So taking that earlier ETL flow,
this is a use case that
we applied with web
traffic data.
We took our web hit data, we
appended some user data to
this, we also appended
some categorization
data for the website.
In other words, how do you divvy
up your site in a way
that makes sense from a
business standpoint?
And then output it to flat files
and use the utilities
that are provided with Google
Cloud Storage and BigQuery to
import it into BigQuery
itself.
One comment I want to make here
is notice that we're,
through this ETL process,
denormalizing data, which is
generally a best practice for
a platform like BigQuery.
But as you'll see later on, it's
not always critical to do
this, and in fact, it may not be
practical to anticipate all
ways in which you want to
denormalize your data.
So this is a shell script we
put together to do the
transfer to BigQuery.
One thing I should mention is
that cloud storage goes
hand-in-hand with BigQuery, so
as an initial step, we're
transferring data into that
environment and using it as a
staging area for import.
First thing we do is
define the bucket.
So this is, if you will, the
file path within cloud storage
to which we're going to
transfer the data.
Within cloud storage, we copy
from our local file system
into that environment.
And in our example, we had this
all running on the same
ETL system that was generating
the output, the CSVs.
And then we call the actual
BigQuery client library to
load the data into our project
with some command line
parameters around how the
file is formatted.
And the thing to note here
is the notation.
I guess Shutterfly.hitdata, in
the relational role, would be
sort of the schema.tablename,
if you will.
So here's an example of a
query that we ran, then.
Once the data is in there,
what were we
able to do with it?
As you can see from the syntax,
it's very familiar to
anyone who has done
a lot of SQL.
And that's really
important to us.
We have an analyst team that
understands SQL quite well,
and uses it as a means to do
a lot of ad hoc analysis.
And so having that familiarity
is great for an option.
We're running this on 2 billion
rows, 400 columns,
about 4 terabytes of data.
Full customer and transactional
detail.
And we ran a variety of
queries, many of which
generally took somewhere between
20 to 60 seconds.
We really didn't have to
do any data modeling.
So we assemble it prior to
loading it, and once it's
loaded, it's a large,
denormalized table.
Don't have to build indexes,
don't have to break out data
into separate columns,
necessarily.
So very efficient from
that standpoint.
In this particular example,
we're looking at the time
spent on the part of the site,
so we're doing a self-join on
that hit data, we're identifying
a population of
customers and where they came
from in the first place, so
those are the attributes
you see with
channel ID and sub ID.
For those that purchase on a
specific day, we're retaining
that customer grain and joining
it back to the hit
data table that contains other
traffic information.
And in this example, we're
looking at their traffic
patterns leading up
to that purchase.
This particular query
ran in five seconds.
So pretty impressive
performance.
Another thing that's valuable
is Big Join.
This is a feature that was
released not too long ago, and
in this example, we're doing
the same sort of pattern.
We're taking a population
of customers.
This time, though, it's
defined outside of
the hit data set.
We're finding basically those
customers that were targeted
in an email campaign and the
segment to which they were
assigned, if we're doing, for
example, subject line testing,
that sort of thing.
We're taking that data set and,
through the Join Each
clause, joining it back
to that hit data.
So Join Each is the syntax for
big joins, and it's joining 10
million rows on the subselect
with the original
2 billion row table.
In this case, Query came back
between five and six minutes,
so very good performance for
the type of operation that
we're doing.
One thing I should mention, I
guess, is you can't always
anticipate all the different
ways in which you're going to
want to denormalize your data or
anticipate the connections
that the business is going
to ask you to do.
And so this is an example
where you can envision
bringing in your own data set
that might be entirely
different, but is still relevant
in that it defines a
population of customers, and
then cross-referencing it with
very large data sets, such
as your web data.
Last example I'll go through
is around pattern matching.
So if you come from a database
background, we've all been
conditioned to never do likes
on strings, or do
pattern-matching, that those
are expensive operations.
And in this example, we're
identifying, again, a
population of customers that
had done a specific event.
And the way it's recorded in the
information is basically
in a comma-delimited field.
And we're doing a regular
expression match to find that
event, and once identified,
again, via the user ID,
joining it back to
the traffic.
And this came back between
three and four minutes.
So again, very fast performance
on regular
expressions of strings that
might be in your data set,
where perhaps it's not
structured when
it first comes in.
Last comment I want to go
through in terms of adoption
is tool compatibility.
So we've been using Tableau
for a while.
It's a very powerful tool
for visualization.
And I wanted to show a couple
of examples of things that
we've done where if you connect
Tableau with these
huge data sets, you can
visualize them in a really
interesting way.
So we've taken a cohort of
images uploaded on a certain
day and looked at the time
between when they were
uploaded and when they were
first taken, and you can see
some really interesting
patterns jump out.
Another example is looking at
when the pictures were taken
at different times of day, and
discerning patterns around how
customers are behaving with
their cameras, and how that
might translate to
product creation.
So that compatibility with
Tableau, and there are other
tools that BigQuery is
integrated with, and I think
that list continues to expand,
but for us it's really
powerful way to get a lot of
summarized data, visualized
data, out of huge data sets.
So conclusions and learnings.
We think this enables new
categories of analysis, and
for us it's retaining
this customer grain.
So that's an important,
I think,
concept to keep in mind.
As analysts, and in particular
in our group, we're often
thinking about customer
behavior, and we need that
level of detail.
We think it'll grow with
the business, so it's a
pay-as-you-go model.
You're not locked into a huge
investment up front.
We also think that this really
empowers the analyst to be
more agile and have
more iterations.
And it improves the efficiency
of IT, as well.
Ultimately it supports our focus
on actionable analytics,
finding the right data
at the right time.
And we think there is a wide
variety of other areas we can
apply this to.
And as I mentioned, this is not
an exhaustive list, but
are some of the areas
that we expect to be
able to leverage this.
We will continue to monitor the
rapid innovation in this
space as well.
And as you probably are very
well aware of, there's a
tremendous amount of
activity on how to
leverage big data sets.
And we'll continue to look at
those right up until Google
decides to buy them.
Just to wrap up, we think we're
tackling some pretty
interesting and complex
analytics.
We are doing it in a way that
is thoughtful, and we're
evaluating a lot of ways to do
that, a lot of interesting
techniques.
And we think BigQuery is
a novel way to do that.
One of the things that's really
important to analysts
is knowing that their analytics
and insights are
being used, in other words,
that there's some decision
being driven out of some new
insight that you have.
And we think we're doing this
in a way that is really
meaningful and insightful,
and we continue to grow.
We've been very fortunate
in our growth.
And hopefully, some of what
we've gone through today has
sparked your interest.
We, as I mentioned, are always
on the lookout for talented
engineers and analysts that
can help us solve some of
these problems.
So come see me afterwards
if any of this is
of interest to you.
Thank you very much.
I'll turn it back
over to Ju-kay.
[APPLAUSE]
JU-KAY KWEK: Thank you
very much, Derek.
Just to summarize, we saw how
Shutterfly, because they're so
focused on good customer
experience and making a great
experience for a very large set
of customers, has really
looked for ways to be innovative
and use analytics
to become more effective
and more efficient
in how they do that.
And one of the things that our
team really loves about this
use case is how practical it
is in terms of the direct
applicability to Shutterfly's
operations as a business, and
we're really glad to see that
they're able to use the
technology to take their
business to the next step, and
to look at new ways of serving
their customers better.
On behalf of the BigQuery team,
we really want to thank
the Shutterfly team and all our
customers for helping us
to learn about this space, solve
new sets of problems out
there in business.
And I just want to say, if
you're using BigQuery already,
we want to hear from you about
these new use cases.
If you're not using BigQuery,
definitely give it a try.
It's part of this larger suite
of cloud platform products--
App Engine, Compute Engine,
cloud storage, many more
things in the pipeline.
And so we strongly encourage
you to take a look.
Novel, efficient, scalable
applications with a very
practical application
to your business.
So we're going to go to Q&A, but
right before that, I just
wanted to highlight a couple of
other sessions that we have
at the conference.
So day one through day three,
we've got some great sessions
that involve BigQuery and also
talk about big data.
So I want to just point out a
few quickly, because I think
it's right after lunch, we've
got a great session with the
Maps team talking about all
the ships in the world.
And so they're actually going to
show some new Maps features
and how they visualize a huge
amount of data about the
geoposition and location of
basically all the ships in the
world at any one time.
It's a really, really cool
session, and they're going to
talk about how they do that.
There's another session--
if you've looked around and
you've seen all these little
devices gathering data, we've
got these Arduino devices that
our developer relations team has
put up, and they've strung
together a great data-sensing
pipeline.
And we're basically measuring
things like humidity and
volume, what's going on in real
time at the conference.
And you see some displays
of this--
I think there's one right
outside, actually--
showing what's going on
in the conference.
The developer relations team is
going to be talking about
how they did this using BigQuery
and the other pieces
of the cloud platform that
I described just now.
Tomorrow there's another great
session run by Gamesys, which
is a gaming company, and
they're going to show a
different use case about how
they used BigQuery and some of
our other services to do a very,
very detailed analysis
of the users, and really help
to drive user behavior and
adoption of their
new features.
So I'll leave this up, and we'll
basically go to about 10
minutes of question
and answer.
And if I can ask, if anyone has
questions, please come up
to the two mics in front
of the aisle.
AUDIENCE: Hi, hello.
Can you talk a little bit about
the tools you use in
order to prepare the data before
uploading to cloud
storage, and also, how long does
it take to upload those
big files, and pricing,
if it's possible?
DEREK STEVENSON: Sure.
So the tools that we use--
we use a variety of ETL tools.
I think there's a lot of
different ways to do it.
We happen to use a combination
of Informatica or Ab Initio.
So those are certainly powerful
tools for doing that
sort of thing, but there's
a wide variety of options
available to you.
Hadoop processing might
be another approach.
In our case, transferring the
data itself, we're fortunate
in that we have pretty good
connections to the internet.
So transferring the data over
was relatively quick.
I can't give you a specific
number, but if you come see me
afterwards, we can certainly
get you that information.
AUDIENCE: Pricing?
Because I guess storing all that
information in Google's
[INAUDIBLE]
must be--
is it expensive?
JU-KAY KWEK: So you
can look this up
online, it's on our website.
But basically, BigQuery is
priced along two vectors.
It's pay-as-you-go right now, so
basically, storage is $0.12
per gigabyte per month.
And that's basically for
multiple replication.
You don't have to manage
any of that.
Your data is very secure.
Then the second pricing is for
queries, and that's priced by
the amount of data you query,
and that's basically 3 and 1/2
cents per gigabyte.
So for example, some of those
large queries might get more
expensive, but the way we've
structured the pricing is that
we believe that if you really
have a large amount of data,
like we saw, and it's really
important to be able to query
that in full grain, then that's
a higher value to you.
So what we've tried to do is
align the pricing with the
value that you get
from the service.
AUDIENCE: And one
last question.
Any plans to integrate this
with Compute Engine?
For example, if I want to do
complex event processing, I
guess Compute Engine will be the
best edition to do that.
JU-KAY KWEK: We have multiple
plans to integrate, not just
with Compute Engine,
but with App
Engine, with the datastore.
I would love to hear about a
specific use case that you
have, and maybe we can point
you in the right direction.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My question is about when
you sometimes get a
result set too large.
Not as the final result, but
as an intermediate result,
like you group each by something
that needs to
generate an intermediate
result set.
Is the only solution to that to
put it in the new table, or
is there another way to deal
with those issues?
JU-KAY KWEK: I see a
few nodding heads.
So result too large is one of
the few limitations that
BigQuery does have.
Basically, what happens is
because we give you the
ability to query a really,
really large data set, it's
equally possible that some of
the results that come back can
be very, very massive,
especially now that we have
things like the Big
Join feature.
So a couple of common
workarounds would be being
very careful to scope out the
number of columns that you
specify in, say, for example,
your select statements.
So the extreme would be select
star, but if you select very,
very specifically, that's one
way of reducing the amount of
total data returned.
Another technique in the
other dimension is to
do with table sharding.
So if you think about how, say,
time series, if you think
about what is the most efficient
query pattern that
you have on your time-- say,
for example, it's a weekly
report but you run, or maybe
it's a daily report that you
run, then it actually makes
sense to design your table
ingestion so that you're
creating a
specific set of tables.
And that way, you can actually
reduce the amount of total
data that gets returned,
as well.
It also is more cost-effective.
AUDIENCE: Paying doesn't
help with that, right?
It's just storage
that you pay.
But you cannot pay to get a
larger intermediate result
set, or something like that.
JU-KAY KWEK: So the question
is, can I pay more to get
larger results?
Unfortunately, you can't do that
now, but if you've looked
at the limits with every
release, we're actually
dramatically increasing
the amount of results
that you can return.
Right now, we've got it up to,
I think it's about 128
megabytes compressed data.
We are going to push that
back, so watch that.
I think you'll like it.
AUDIENCE: Thanks,
JU-KAY KWEK: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey, guys.
So I had a question about
the import process.
You mentioned in your diagram
one of the steps was to
actually take the data and
put it into CSV files.
And then you also mentioned
that it's optimal to
denormalize the data, but then
you also mentioned that there
were scenarios that it might
not be optimal to
denormalize all of it.
So I'm wondering, from when
you make that decision to
denormalize data or to keep
it normalized, what--
I understand the reason
why you would want
to denormalize it.
But can you give a couple
examples, why you would want
to leave it normalized, and
then, does it have an impact
on a BigQuery perspective?
JU-KAY KWEK: Maybe I can address
that with just with a
few comments, and actually, I'd
love it, because Derek has
a great thought process
about this.
Table denormalization is
basically an efficiency that
allows you to very, very quickly
work against the data.
The question is, why have we
recommended that, and then
also increase the
ability to join?
The answer to that is, we've
noticed a lot of different
styles, legitimate needs
to query the data
in different ways.
So to give an example
from Shutterfly--
I'll hand it over to you in a
second-- what we noticed is
basically, if you think about
data within the organization,
not all data is equally divided
up, and there's
certain things that make more
sense to cluster together.
And so what Shutterfly did was
to pull that together into a
kind of domain silo of data, and
when you need to bring in
a new set, or when you need to
look at the other part of the
organization and bring in data
from there, that's when Join
is very useful.
But why don't you comment on
that from your experience?
DEREK STEVENSON: Sure.
I think it's not so much that
you don't want to denormalize.
It's more that circumstances
dictate that you can't
denormalize.
So if you've spent time building
an infrastructure
that denormalizes and imports
that into BigQuery, and now
you realize there's this new
category of data that you want
to connect, the process of going
through that pipeline
again and reloading your data to
BigQuery, because it's sort
of a write once model, isn't
always practical.
Or if it's something you know
you need to do, it's going to
take some time.
So as an interim step, you can
imagine where an analyst can
put together their own data set
on their desktop or laptop
and import it directly, and
not be bogged down with
needing to hand that
over to IT, to flow
through that pipeline.
AUDIENCE: Thanks, guys.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I had a question if you
evaluated any other
alternatives that came up as
second place runners-up, maybe
in-house solutions, or if you
found anything that you maybe
tried that didn't quite work.
Our data is kind of the same
ballpark as yours, and I've
been playing with BigQuery and
been very happy with it, but
I've also been trying to find
other things that maybe are in
the same-- you maybe don't get
your query in 20 seconds, but
you can get it in 15 minutes
or something, instead of
overnight, like Hive and
solutions like that.
Did you play with anything
like that?
DEREK STEVENSON: So we have
looked at those options and
continue to evaluate where
those best fit.
I think, to comment on Hive and
Hadoop, for example, our
core competency from an
engineering standpoint is
really focusing on product
development.
So how do customers save time in
how they create photo books
and things like that.
So our primary focus isn't
necessarily building a team to
manage a Hadoop environment.
So some of our constraints are
perhaps more practical and
less technical.
They're also taking
into account the
personnel side of things.
I think that's certainly one
direction you could go.
We've also looked at column
store databases.
Typically the pricing structure
with those requires
kind of a big upfront
commitment, and so those are
more difficult conversations
with the folks
that sign the checks.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
Did you try anything like a
relational database type,
MySQL or Postgres or
anything like that?
DEREK STEVENSON: A lot of our
existing approaches use those
tools and techniques, but we
feel like the complexity to
work around some of the
constraints are pretty
difficult to do in a
scalable fashion.
But I'd be happy to chat
more after the
session, if you'd like.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
Are there any plans to make
AdWords data available in
BigQuery data sets?
JU-KAY KWEK: AdWords
data specifically?
I would say that--
I can't answer that
specifically, but if you look
at what's going on, one of the
sessions actually today is
about Google Analytics
and AdSense.
I think you can get a
sense of where we're
going with all of this.
And so we definitely
see the value.
We hear a lot of it from
our customers.
If you have a situation
where-- it
sounds like you do--
I'd love to hear more about it,
actually, to understand
the requirements together with
the different Ads teams.
Do you happen to use, say,
Google Analytics?
Do you use AdSense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we do.
I mean, our AdWords
data reports
are hundreds of gigabytes.
So it's a bit inefficient to
download 100 gigs and then
re-upload it to Google
while you guys
already have that data.
If we're doing all that work
anyway, that opens up the
space to competitors, because
we're also now
looking at AWS Redshift.
But if you guys made that
data available, it
would be the clincher.
We'd go straight to BigQuery.
JU-KAY KWEK: We actually have
some members of the
Analytics team here.
We'd love to actually hear a
little bit more about this.
We have a couple of things that
we're trying, that if
you're interested, we'd
love to work with you.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
I'll chat with you afterwards.
JU-KAY KWEK: Great.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I would like to ask you if you
can share with us some
information about limitation,
about the number of the column
that a table can have.
I mean, I know that in order to
get best performance using
Google BigQuery, we should
normalize all the data.
So if I have to create a table
from merging a lot of
different tables, I would like
to know the maximum number of
columns I can have.
JU-KAY KWEK: We actually have
some uses where customers with
tables with columns
in the thousands.
So as far as practical limits
go, I think you can scale
quite significantly in a
horizontal fashion-- probably
more than you'll have
column needs for.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Do you have any plans to
introduce an OBDC driver so we
can access the data more
efficiently from Excel and
from other tools?
JU-KAY KWEK: So we
don't publicly
advertise an ODBC driver.
There are companies, third
parties unrelated to Google,
that have done things like
produce the JDBC driver, if
you go and search out there.
Those do exist.
There is actually a connector,
an Excel
connector, for BigQuery.
AUDIENCE: It limits it in that
the number of results that you
can return is pretty small,
and you have to return the
results and then manipulate
them in Excel.
So that's really where
the issue came in.
OK.
I'll have to look for
those third parties.
The other question that I've got
is, where BigQuery falls
down for us is the limitation
on handling GIS data.
So we want to be able to take
latitudes and longitudes and
say, well, tell me what the zip
code is, and aggregate by
zip code, analyze by state.
And we just find that the
limitations in BigQuery today,
working with GIS data--
I mean, there really isn't
any ability to do that.
So I'd recommend that if there
is an option in future to
extend or to handle GIS data,
it would be tremendously
useful for us.
JU-KAY KWEK: So I think the
obvious one is the session
afterwards on the ships is
probably going to be of
interest to you, especially
how they built that app.
It's actually quite easy to
integrate things like the Maps
API with BigQuery API.
Obviously that's not the easiest
solution right now,
but those are some of
the things that
are possible today.
Another thing that we have seen
is we have some customers
who have done geo-based
analysis using
BI tools like Tableau.
Tableau does a great job of
throwing up, you mentioned zip
code and so on.
We actually have a case study
that we're working on where
they do exactly that.
AUDIENCE: Interesting.
Thank you.
JU-KAY KWEK: I'll tell
you more if you're
going to hang around.
AUDIENCE: Sounds good.
Thanks.
WES CHEN: Just a follow-up.
So just FYI, I think Google App
Engine has a Search API
but also has [? geo-searching ?]
as well.
So if your data
[? is something ?] extremely
large, or if you need a subset
of the data that you
[INAUDIBLE], send it to App
Engine Datastore [INAUDIBLE]
use the Search API to
search [INAUDIBLE].
JU-KAY KWEK: And just to repeat
that because it wasn't
on the mic, that's
Wes Chen from our
Developer Relations team.
App Engine Search API actually
has the ability to handle
geo-searching and store
those points in
the App Engine Datastore.
Thanks for the question.
I'd love to hear more
about that.
And thank you all for
your attention
and your great questions.
Thank you for using
the product.
You help us to make it better.